hey guys welcome back to brainy video
we're back on apex legends again and
today we're gonna be talking about a new
update that was just released on the
apex legends reddit
this is gonna be going over some of the
changes that are gonna be happening on
the release day of season 1 and kind of
what the devs are thinking this includes
a wingman
nerf a peacekeeper nerve and a buff to
the larger hitbox heroes and other stuff
so as always like the V if you do enjoy
subscribe for new I covered the
informational side of apex legends that
being the balance changes the hero
updates the legend updates the new
battle paths stuff like that see for now
if you want to recap today with
everything happening in the world of
apex legends if we stay subscribe to the
channel and with that let's get started
first up has to do with the reason of
the skull piercing wingman attachment so
the reason that this exists of course is
to increase more headshot damage and
stuff like that but the reason that they
want to talk about this is because it's
on the stronger end of things and they
want to keep the wingman as a high tier
weapon because they believe that if you
have good accuracy you should be
rewarded with good amount of damage
that's why the wingman damage is not
going to go down but other bits and
parts of it are going to which we'll
talk about right now so for the wingmen
the rate of fire has been reduced from
three point one to two point six shots
per second so they're going to be firing
the weapon a little bit slower than
before and the headshot damage
multiplier is now reduced from 2.5 to
2.25 so a little bit less you're not
beginning so you're not gonna be getting
as much of damage and you're not going
to be getting as much rate of fire as
before with the wingman and next up was
the Peacekeeper and this was only nerfed
for the shotgun bolt so for example they
have level 1 level 2 and level 3 and
just in case you're unfamiliar level 1
is white level 2 is blue and level 3 is
purple so the level 1 mitigation is 10%
that is now 7.5 level 2 mitigation is
20% now that is 13% and level 3
mitigation was originally 25 so it now
it's down to 16 so in order it's going
to be 7.5 13 and then 16 mitigation for
the shotgun bolt which is the reach
ambering rate on the Peacekeeper on top
of that they've also reduced the amount
of peacekeepers and wingman's that
you're going to be seeing in all zone
tiers throughout the game but also
increasing the availability of energy
weapons and the energy ammo as well
which is really nice to see one thing
that they wanted to point out was why is
there no P 2020 and Mozambique buffs now
the Mozambique has been such a huge meme
it's one of the worst gun
in the game and they understand that but
they want to have what's called a power
curve so they want really bad weapons to
be a lot more common whereas the good
weapons show up a lot less frequently
which is why you don't see too many gold
weapons where it's the entire weapon
with all the attachments laid on it
whereas you see Mozambique's everywhere
on the map they want to make the
Mozambique in the twenty20 very similar
to this they want to have it so that the
weapon is better than a melee attack but
as soon as you get a new weapon you want
to get that weapon out of your inventory
ASAP that's the type of weapon class
that those two fit in because of how bad
they are and that's what they originally
wanted they will be continuing to
listening to player feedback on if they
can possibly improve the Mozambique in
the P 2020 so that it's still at the
bottom of the list but not exactly 100%
garbage so I'll have to see later in the
future on a major balance changes
they're going to be reducing the hitbox
size reduction and optimization for the
bigger characters like caustic and
Gibraltar as well as Pathfinder as you
guys already know Costigan gibraltar of
some of the two bigger characters in the
game i'm not actually sure about
pathfinder he might be
middle-of-the-road
but they do want to reduce the hitboxes
on him just because of how big he is but
they also want to do is not jump the gun
right away and start nerfing the better
characters like wraith who has a very
small if not the small stick box in the
game they actually want to increase the
power of the larger raid characters like
Gibraltar and caustic before they start
doing the nerves which is a really nice
thing that they're gonna be doing so
after the major balance changes they
talked about the minor balance changes
there's going to be a legend specific so
we have caustic Pathfinder life line
Wraith and Bangalore in this one for
caustic and his traps it's going to
reduce the cooldown from 25 from 30
seconds so it's gonna be a little bit
quicker the reduced radius and proximity
radius by 10% as well as removing the
one second delay on the smoke dealing
damage to player so that's going to be
for caustic straps for Pathfinder he has
the insider knowledge it's going to
increase the number of beacons in the
world from 12 to 10 so you have a lot
more access and you can use these a lot
more and more frequent areas lifeline
her care package is gonna be removed
slight chance that level 4 armor and
helmets will drop so you don't always
get a lot of gold that's gonna be more
frequent purples and blues and not too
much gold so that people have to rely on
her as much rates into the void move
which I believe is her tactical booty
where she goes invisible that
cool down is gonna be increased from 20
seconds it's not it was originally 20
and now it's going to be 25 seconds so
it's gonna take you a little bit longer
to use that move every so often and
they've reduced the moving speed bonus
of bangalore's double-time move from
forty percent down to thirty percent but
as i said guys the Peacekeeper in the
wingman nerf i believe are currently in
the game now alive on all platforms
whereas the hip boxes and the nerfs and
the slash buffs to the other legends
that's probably going to be coming in
season one when the battle past does
release now there is no date on when
that is releasing they still have to get
some of the things done but they're
almost done with it so it should
probably not be too long maybe a week or
two at most before we can actually get
into season one of apex legends hey guys
it's gonna be the end of the video I
hope you guys did enjoy let me know your
thoughts and the Peacekeeper and the
wingman nerfs
I do believe that the wingmen did need
to be nerfed it was a tad bit strong
some people said that the extended mags
should have been gone from the game I
don't really see if too big of an issue
with that but I'm also not really
ashamed of the fire rate as well I
definitely do not believe the damage
needs to be nerfed personally to me if
you have good accuracy you will be
rewarded with high damage that should
help that's really how this weapon is
and how it should be and that's what I
think is really cool about it we had
like the V if you to enjoy subscribe if
you're new I cover the informational
side of apex legends so if you never
want to miss an entire update ever
definitely stay subscribed to the
channel and with that guys my two most
recent videos will be on screen if you
guys do want to check that out but that
guy so whoever grades today take four
hours to the video and peace out into
the rest of your day
[Music]
you
[Music]